foreign
[Music]
I'd like to play a game
perhaps one that addresses those sticky
I've had my eyes on you and I do not
like what I see
your job as a custodian is a noble one
sanitizing and sterilizing the hospital
helping patients avoid sickness
there is a sickness inside you that
needs to be exercised you have the
ability to not only save your soul today
but your sight
all you have to do is click the dial
across the five positions and you will
live to see another day but even 60
seconds helpless
all right
the cancer is still spreading I'm afraid
there's nothing else we can do there is
one person who might be able to help our
program is a two-pronged treatment
outside Mexico City the results have
been stunning she saved my life
you're in very good hands with us
after that what happens then your whole
life happens to me John Kramer
according to these scans the tumor was
never removed how much time do I have
months at best I still have a lot of
work that needs to be done
[Music]
hello everyone it's time to play a game
we all pretended to kill me but what I
have planned for each of you is very
real
[Music]
the only thing I have not provided is
your anesthetic but trust me
you will want to remain alert
[Music]
of all the men to cheat you picked John
Kramer please don't hesitate place a big
enough piece of your cerebral tissue
into the glass enzyme tank this will
save your life
silence
it's not retribution it's a Reawakening
[Music]
little dog the choice is yours
foreign